what's happening there reject nation greg and
john back at it to watch the boys episode five
today that's right we got mics now yay hey there
better audio yes all righty well if you guys can
leave a like we'd very much appreciate that helps
design the algorithm and leave your thoughts down
below what you thought about this episode also
subscribe and click that notification bell to get
notified when our reaction for episode six is up
is that i'm gonna be here orgasm oh my god is that
one thank you i think that one was your guys is it
this one i don't know either way full length watch
alarms we sync up with the time code for the boys
over at our patreon page for super sexy rejects at
the same tier you get the option for reaction
highlights and watch alongs included for some
other shows as well then boys at prepper thank you
for helping us out these highlights and with the
consistent yellow dollar bill signs limit
there's no ads for the boys want to thank
athletic greens for sponsoring this video
genuinely like uh when we started partnering
up with athletic greens they don't want me to say
this i didn't just say this for my own heart i've
been drinking them every single day for like the
past month and john's been drinking one right now
uh yeah we genuinely really like your
stuff and also as you know two people who
have been having a crazy schedule lately and
not really sleeping much it's been hard to
get some exercise in something that's really
been helping maintain some energy and focus
maybe it's placebo maybe it's authoritarians
i don't know it's been helping me feel more
energetic and i haven't been bloated
lately so yeah thank you athletic greens
fire forgot to wear my
supernatural shirt dab you greg
it's a radiation sulfuric acid
cocktails more or less right up his arms
i would watch that hbo series
gnarly the whole point of what we do
the whole god damn point is that no
one should have that kind of power well
ain't that just [__] fairies and dancing
dildos hey i am to live right down here mate
oh yeah
what no kid brother feeling
a little responsibility
the greatest humility i accept your
nomination as ceo of vaught international
okay ashley that's enough let's not bring the
room down apologies sir of course hello everyone
sorry i'm late no power with the changes around
here our ebitda margins will drop a tiny bit
how do you want to handle that on the earnings
call do you think you know better than me
oh you should be sitting in my chair and i
should be sitting all the way down there in yours
oh god no sir i'm so stupid and you're so great
maureen you're embarrassing yourself you should go
justice for marine allow me to introduce you
to the new head of crime analytics the deep
oh god no if you work hard enough there's nothing
you can't achieve hashtag dream big because
vaudel makes you the right man sorry barbara
right person gets the job so to break the ice
cupcakes cupcakes from sprinkles enough
for everybody homelander killed alex
he [__] murdered him and it's all
my fault hey it is not your fault
come here come here you guys
could have been smarter about it
let me take care of you for a second tell me
you found it moscow was a dead end i'm sorry
what don't lie man come on you know
what i'm gonna get you a white claw
would you like a fresca what uh part you're
most upset about is it the part where
uh soldier boy is loose in russia or the part
where i took some temporary compound v it could
be both parts uh all the parts that's that's
no secrets that's got to be worth some points
kiwi man of the year you could have gotten
yourself killed we don't have any more and
even if we did i wouldn't take it it was awful the
hangover all of it just absolutely hated it yeah
sure you did you loved it i [__] really loved it
it was awesome i mean you know me that was stupid
and dangerous i can't lose you too oh god i'm
sorry i'm sorry you're right it's over yeah okay
comrade soldier boy
god damn there better be a full-on
soldier boys that's pretty good
what are you gonna do with those
no thanks i've been sober four
months it's been a year for me
no god damn it man you are such a toxic
influencer this is not going to go well
used to be mum so they've worked to tell you how
to suit gunpowder not even the new york minute
it must have felt good oh my god they're going to
do it aren't they they're going to do it all of
it does is just all that [__] that's already
inside and it's not just homelander i mean you
[__] all got to go every [__] lost one of you
yeah but they're bored into this it's different
than being an adult who starts taking yeah
it's thrust upon you before you know what to do
oh there we go oh no hero foreplay
i i i got this feeling in my bones
oh god nuclear erection time
i did not think there were going to hear what
this season is nope get it maeve it was me
who came to you made a deal with you
take it up with him i don't know him
i know you always who says you're the one who
pays the debt you work for me now poor frenchie
you author see me and elvine's daughter katarina
you do it today oh my god call me money's done
oh you hot russian [__] did
i say she's hot yeah i meant it
it's you it's you how's it going
what happened it was your point gosh
why does she have a smile is she not super anymore
let's run some human tests
it's really dangerous that soldier can do that
what an interesting way to introduce
that though congrats from lindsey graham
homelander has agreed to a meeting with you in
blue hawk okay great hi hey thanks for coming on
such short notice hey train hey oh no i wanted
to talk to you about your patrols and training
a little excessive says who well a lot of
black folks this has nothing to do with
african americans see what i did there
and you don't want people to say that
you're being racist right you know it's
actually racist to call somebody racist
make an apology or some [__] what a
great idea thank you for saying that
maybe patrol other neighborhoods
bobby bobby itch it
crazy tonight
oh you're not definitely not
for that that's a realistic take
next you'll tell me women have the right to vote
oh wow real winter soldier effector
can't wait for them to interact oh dude maybe the
best way to handle this is to find him i never
thought of that obviously god okay so why don't
you go and do that run along and save the day tell
me this isn't who i think it is probably exactly
what you think it is oh my god look we're coming
on the site now can your crime analytics people
look for him i'm on it just be careful haley
you should never have a conversations
right outside a homeland store
i'm just saying and without like other [__]
playing like you were doing with superstars
damn look at that destruction wow
didn't you break your arm yes it turns out it's
a bad sprain so i'm okay i'll see you later okay
can't be leaving breadcrumbs like that
let's just focus on the job at end
let me help you with soulja boy oh yeah
that much and then you don't go see me
okay yes have a little v on me
where is everyone we are everyone deep fired
mostly department what oh you prick deep rich man
you should not be doing this man this
is a terrible idea oh this is so bad
is this what you wanted for me to use my
platform to help the community right five minutes
oh dude a fight's gonna totally break
to the residents of trenton thank
you for giving me the opportunity
apologize if any of mine have been perceived
as being racist but that is not who i am
okay just ask my friends many of
whom are are black like a train
excellent
and there's a sign of my commitment to you all
what about what you did to raymond tucker would
you have done the same thing to a white guy in
mill hill i go with the crimes and the crime just
happens to be in black neighborhoods
that's not my fault oh you dumbass oh dude
i was acting in self-defense black
lives matter walk away all lives matter
soup lives matter shut the
[__] up oh yeah yep yep oh
oh you prick
true no i couldn't have seen that
[__] coming man saint grubhub
from stranger things to the boys i was balls deep
in golden giesha and marlon brando was apparently
balls deep in me what that's gay now [__] you
who cares what's the difference anyway after that
legend soulja boy came to see you need to know
what he said what are you crazy robin he's a
[__] doornail so who's that coke for that's
just me i'm writing my memoir it's gonna be
really dynamites oh my god a soldier boy in there
you forget what happened last time i helped the
underage hooker sting on electroshock oh oh
hey there i thought i was staring at a ghost
but it was him he hadn't aged the day though
it got a little fishy when he started in that
loving war picture with phoebe cates he was 63
she was 19. oh [__] uh why was soulja boy here
came to pick up his super suit
i'm sentimental although i did
actually wear the suit once for kelly lebrock
this guy's such a producer big l big b the other
letters he also came for his girlfriend's address
i didn't get the feeling it was gonna be a happy
reunion but i don't know maybe you can go
there and find out america is safe okay it
is safe so everyone get out there go to your
restaurants and uh go to your movie theater
drink some bleach eat a tide bud you're out to
get me aren't you what are you talking about
it's smelling all over you oh my god john come
on i'm not cooking anything up with butcher
let's talk about this oh she there [__] doing me
you could play this way smarter mate yeah you know
the real tragic thing in all of this was anything
about us ever real it's a good question actually
oh my god
damn it's like a flak noir phantom i hope you got
a almond joy up your sleeve up your gauntlet i
mean who do you guys want do you guys want gawky
weak freaking the [__] out huey or do you want
strong confident handling of [__] huey oh my god
this is way more psychologically worse for huey
what the [__] did he do to maeve that's
all right gregory maeve is at the global
wellness retreat in malibu asking for help uh we
can't let him do this who are you referring to
i know you're scared i am too but this
ceo job it can't be worth your life
oh my god homeland is right there
you don't need power take some v
please where is maeve she even alive
uh oh she's retreating i am ceo a plus real
boss move lacerations to vertebrae t6 t7
t8 and t9 the damage is so severe that nathan
will never walk again you got to be kidding me
you know to think that my donation to this
community would be met with such intolerance
just breaks it oh my god he's gonna
actually start genuinely caring
yeah it's not real until it comes to your door
i'm so worried french is going to die
this season i've got rhythm i got music
yes
oh no
this is so wonderful and i'm so uneasy
there's a full musical number i know
not bad love it more
foreign
is
oh my my dude oh wow so the first or second
season he tried kissing her and she really did not
no
outbreak technically those aren't
chimps circumstances suporn
he played himself in the last two
seasons he played himself again
that he is exactly what seth rogens into
1950 per minute get that spandex down
start popping those things in there
whoa your lover boy's on his way here soldier
boy he's alive how do you escape from russia oh
she sold them out yeah yeah we're sure
hollisan will work look that way in the
reds video we knock them out we keep them
out then we figure out what to do with them
what the hell is going on mm-hmm oh no oh
amy what are you doing here mm called me oh
you're probably gonna be mad but
i promise no more secrets right so
whoa oh my god
yikes i'd know that crackle anywhere
oh oh no oh butcher what'd you do
you serious man
my god he's back
oh he cleaned up trim that beard you want
to counter says hit on a spunk don't you
consider it a gesture of good faith
good faith for what i was thinking that you and
i have come to a little arrangement oh my god
crossover it wasn't my idea god you gotta believe
me how much did the russians pay you they didn't
they didn't pay you anything all those years
that they burned me pumped me for the poison
i held on to the hope that you would go because
i still loved you i hated you got bald countess
oh you just signed your deathwood man
let us handle this you can yell at me
damn they really went far away
to talk i hope that mm got away
okay he's had four or five legs
everywhere no you [__] roofied him
i need you to fight homelander team up
jurassic park
works on everything
oh my god hugh is on the same page already
he's how we kill homelander and newman
maybe if anyone's strong enough he is you knew
butcher was going to do this never would have
gone for it and you look you weren't supposed
to be here this is so bad so bad i'm doing
this for you whatever it takes are you remember
whatever it takes you're thinking please don't go
i mean i kind of get both sides though you
need something where i get so blind or jesus
witness an awesome display of power wow that
was like just a straight up drama episode yeah
with a musical number wow this really is
darker season next one will be so much fun
so it's a little bit more
soldier boy every episode
the last one is gonna be a solo episode one
location only soldier boy oh [__] hell my
this [__] show i doubt there's a post credit
scene all right let's talk about it let's
talk about that all right well before we
talk about this episode before we review it
which i thought was another great episode very
somber this one it's been more of a somber season
overall a word from today's sponsor thank you to
athletic greens for partnering up with us once
again no joke when we first started partnering
up with them i wasn't as familiar with athletic
greens and for the past month in between that
time i had to move and there's been a whole lot
coming out so exercise and sleep has been very
much limited so definitely needed something to
maintain energy to remain reasonably healthy
we've been having athletic greens every single day
for over a month now about over a month yeah it's
100 true i feel like it's made a total difference
in my life i fully attest to it uh ordered some
of our own as well on top of the ones they already
shipped to us so i'm hoping that we can save
partner with them for as long as possible because
i really do feel like it's been a major health
influence in our lives john why don't you go ahead
and tell them what it is that we've been taking
absolutely we've been taking their ag-1 formula
which is comprised of 75 high-quality vitamins
minerals superfoods adaptogens probiotics and more
and what's great about it is it's an all-in-one
formula so it's way cheaper than trying to get all
those things individually and then come up with
some kind of regimen and it definitely has us
feeling sharper especially on these more sleepless
nights it keeps us feeling relatively physically
clean and fresh as well yeah sometimes i take it
twice a day usually first thing in the morning
right when i wake up on an empty stomach if i have
an opportunity to work out i'll mix it with like
half of a pre-workout and a lot of times if i
actually have like a bad meal i will have it at
night before i go to bed and yeah i really do
stand by this i really believe in the product
a lot so yeah no we're not making all the funny
jokes that we usually make because yeah we are
mentally clear and alert right now thanks to ag-1
in order to make these claims but also the great
thing too is your subscription is less than three
dollars a day for athletic greens and when you
use our special link athleticgreens.com rejects
you'll receive some free gifts as well including
a year's supply of vitamin d which you know not
everybody gets as much sun as we do here in la
so take advantage of that for sure so yeah thank
you athletic greens really stand by everything we
just said right now and happy to be partnering up
with you guys because it's it's been very helpful
thank you all right uh we're where to kick it
off with no boom well i mean let's kick it off
with it let's talk about soldier boy i feel
like it's what everybody wants to to get to
yeah yeah god i just keep craving more gents and
apples i know [__] they're really like cocktails
in the spring they are getting to the point where
i'm like there better be like just so much soldier
and it better not kill him off like you better be
coming back for the next season because it's just
been one build up after another and it's getting
me like antsy for more more of him like i can't
even really review the performance yet like i like
what jensen ackles is doing i like the teases that
we've been getting i appreciated those subtle
little nods uh not no i don't know references
but yeah because i remember it uh it's
not steve trevor wait yeah steve trevor
oh my god it's been a long day no steve rogers is
captain america steve trevor is wonder woman yeah
and in one room in 84 that was a comment that was
a joke that was definitely going around about like
he's uh they're all surprised by the amount
of conclusion and diversity in the streets
yeah yeah yeah yeah all the updated sensibilities
and stuff yeah sorry like i did like they actually
included that little hint at the kind of point
of view this character has interracial couples
what because i want them to push the boundaries
but especially with getting jensen ackles in here
knowing his relationship with eric kripke from
supernatural and you know just coming off of the
ending of supernatural i want them to go really
bold with you know putting him in here um because
i i'm aware that it's going to get like very
sexual it's going to get like extremely sexual
uh like i i i'm i'm already concerned about i know
we're gonna not gonna keep that video monetized
but a lot of trouble getting i just don't
want it to get taken off of youtube it is
or just be one big blur yeah i i want i just
wanted to be able to live on the channel so
that i am already a bit nervous about that
one but he's talked about on seth meyer's
show like yeah there's gonna be some like crazy
sexual stuff that he his character has to do um
but i want them to go really bold with it because
yeah i'm not even i don't really have a sense of
yet who this character is other than the the you
know carrying over like we haven't really explored
who he is as a person yet like we're still
still yet to grasp um you know what is his
association with the world was his personality
going to be like is he going to be more anti-hero
is going to be straight-up villain you know how
are they going to mesh all this we all have our
theories and predictions of how this can go down
especially for those who've really dived into the
the source material but i'm i'm still waiting
for what is the what is the portrayal because
yeah it's a lot of it is very much currently just
a big riff on captain america and both winter
soldier um a strong clash of both of them and you
know but a more of a realistic version of it all
yeah yeah yeah so yeah that ending scene you
know because for crimson countess his girlfriend
because they were saying like everyone hated
you you know she's saying that to him and you
know really believe that speech he was giving when
he was you know lamenting that the sorrow of not
of feeling like he kept hoping you would come
to me and rescue me but everyone hated him
and yet we didn't really we haven't seen much of
why why did everyone hate him yeah and it's not a
complaint it's just i'm waiting for that before
i can really dive into like jets and apples is
performance yeah totally because they're just
giving you i i like right now i'm really enjoying
the pacing of the show for those things getting
yeah a little bit we start to hear whispers about
this weapon something to do with soldier boy we
see a few flashbacks and then increasingly we get
just more glimpses of who he is but i like that
they've kept most of his character as seen through
everybody else's eyes who knew him who was there
for the history through mm and with him too like
i thought you know the way that they're going
about teaming up with soldier boy potentially
and also gearing up to maybe have to deal with him
as a physical threat i thought the way they tied
that into everything with butcher and huey and
especially mm has been really nice too and that
gradual you know pushing towards the edge because
i think you know it's i wouldn't say it's like a
completely foregone conclusion but i like that
in this episode mm doesn't actually take the v
it's like i feel like it will happen there will be
that breaking point that line that he will cross
but at the same time i like that here you know you
get those moments of tension where you're like it
looks like he might be ready to snap and do it but
he's really trying to hold on to his moral compass
because that's what this is all about and i think
it's really nice that they keep that in mind
because it's easy to lose yourself in the fantasy
and in you know the darker implications of the
philosophy but i think that is the trickiest one
is like how do you defeat such depraved enemies
without becoming depraved yourself and negating
the whole process well the this process is like
like it's just so not thought out on what they're
doing you know if you have if you do ultimately
have a weapon i think it's going down a path
where soldier boy and homelander i think in the
comics they slept together oh yeah let's see that
i don't want i don't think they're going to do it
for that whole hour i want that yeah i i don't
think they're going to do that but i think they
are going to form a kinship i think they are going
to form a bond and i feel like that's kind of what
they're alluding to sort of a like that that
when homelander was watching him a bit of this
interest or desire or something i'm not sure
exactly what it was but definitely a curiosity
about him that felt more than just a like it's
it's and then with the little teasers we've gotten
about the kind of individual that soldier boy is i
would venture to guess that they're probably going
to form some type of bond and it is not going to
go according to plan but i'm like even if it did
go according to plan like come on guys you're
not thinking this through if you did have this
ultimate human weapon who was able to take down
homelander but this guy's a horrible dude how are
you going to take down the guy how are you going
to take down the thing takes on homeland or then
yeah yeah if you've ever played you've literally
just swapped your problem for the same problem
yeah yeah so um yeah i that it just seems
like one big compounding problem after another
and an adventure to guess that mm that like when
that when this plan goes to [__] that mm would
then have to take some v24 to then try to take
down soldier boy but like i said i just don't
want them to get rid of soldier boy this season
if they do ultimately end up killing him but i do
really like the darkness so far of him like it's
such like jensen ackles is an amazing if you've
seen supernatural that's obviously the work that
most including ourselves are mainly familiar with
the guy in um and where you got to see most of his
range and that show you do get a lot of different
ranges of that one portrayal where you do
see a lot of versatility with that actor
and i'm like oh yeah no dead sandals toy pull
this roll off uh but yeah i mean they are doing a
like this this [__] back and forth thing with
like huey and starlight you know like first it's
the first season is huey is uh brina prete is is
falling in love with her but he's working with the
boys and you know she's a part of the the seven
the enemy and then in the second season you know
like she doesn't really trust him and they are
you know by the end of it they they end up getting
back together and here they're filing together
and now these choices and i like the how they're
doing the v24 as a as as a drug analogy you know
getting hooked on drugs and using it as a crutch
you know it's like when it's such a different
conversation with butcher who's kind of
surrendering to something as an extension to take
down things but he already displays confidence
here he displays strength he he's already proven
himself where he can he can handle certain [__]
now he's just using this whereas huey is
like i am a completely different human being
and i like that person i can i i feel like
i'm actually i can contribute something
physically to the team finally you know and
so it's it's a very different psychological
relationship with v24 versus what butcher has and
i think it's cool that they're able to draw both
like two different dynamics with uh taking the
drug um you know in a way that doesn't feel
like repetitive or just watching two characters
go through the same thing um with the with the
same vice or the same crutch i i think that's
really neat how they're um uh drawing that
and uh it was heartbreaking at that end you
know it didn't feel like just another repetitive
uh come on of course they're together now they're
not going to be together thing it's like uh huey
he keeps saying he's doing this for starlight but
it's there's more than that that he's doing it for
because of how it makes him feel as a as an
individual and you know as someone who's always
trying to teeter on because because since season
one they've teased huey just eventually getting
to a breaking point of pure darkness and you know
it brings it back to that because huey really was
the main character of of the first season and um
like at least i thought so and you know it seemed
like it was all drawn from his perspective for the
most part and now it's sort of bringing it back to
that trajectory of what's going on with that
character too and i think jack white's doing
an amazing job yeah no totally and i'm i mean
it already there was that theme brought up in
the mave scene about you know it's all this stuff
drugs whatever else v24 it all just makes you more
of you it just amplifies what's already
in there and i know that there's that
aspect of huey was like no i'm a totally different
guy but you do get that hint at the end of we're
right back here to you using this no more lies
thing to just cover up a bigger set of omitted
truths yeah and so what more from the things
that huey is trying to run away from are going
to make it into his uh you know personality and
physicality as he goes further and further down
the v24 rabbit hole and i mean yeah like that's a
plotline that could easily become like oh come on
you know like wheel spinning and wrote but it
feels like yeah there's just given this world
that we live in and starlight's position and
huey's position especially you know as inter
abilities you know couple it seems like there's
a natural order in which it would be hard for
them to ever have a happy relationship and uh and
yeah i appreciated that quite a bit and uh i mean
god this was not a very like homelander-centric
episode i did enjoy like the little bits of him
this is almost the episode where he was like too
distracted with learning how to run vaught and
being like oh god this is a lot for for this is
more than i bargained for kind of um but you know
even so i thought they made his moments very
still like impactful each time he was there
that whole thing with maeve is is nasty and
chilling well being able to smell butcher on
her i mean the way she tried lying her way out of
it oh you're being pretty obvious me yeah i think
i think as an actor it was kind of an intentional
choice because i think the way she was playing
start collecting for me halfway through the
scene because at first i'm like oh my god
bad lying but i i it started i'm not just saying
this to be kind it it did strike me as i know i
think the scene was played intentionally like
bad line because it was more of a demonstration
she had to be doing bad lying because to get
to the point where you're divulging the whole
truth that even when we were like dating and and
sleeping with each other i had hated you since day
one and i have feared you since day one so to
get to the point of letting that go it's like
the lying had to be bad as a sign of she's not
even trying her best to cover this up yeah like
she wants to yeah that's a good point i mean
it felt very like cliche horror music got me
as a jump scare it was like still kind of like
goofy when i look back i'm like black no orange
yeah yeah with the bag it's a little goofy but
it's looking at me yeah at the jump scare moment
yeah but i thought it did sell me like i think
what they've done so well with the season is
uh more than the other ones is a homelander
could just kill anyone at any time now
he always had that ability but now it just seems
like he there's like nothing and no one to stop
this guy at any given moment not even ashley no
not even not even oh god and all this stuff with
a train this episode was gnarly there are parts
of the writing of it though where i did i have no
issue at all with them uh infusing like political
stuff uh it's never been a i've never been like
[__] up and i've never had an issue with that
i do think some of it is is a little too overt
like i mean i mean i feel like still do it like
i'm like yeah you can still do black lives matter
all lives matter cancel culture like you can
totally still do all that i i might this is a
subjective taste i personally prefer it when it's
a little bit more like you're replacing words
instead to not make it as obvious you know like i
preferred it when he was saying soups lives matter
versus like immediately going black lives matter
all lives matter like okay now you're not even
you know you're just so direct about it yeah
like okay so in the world of the boys all these
movements have also been happening totally where
i liked it better when they are doing a commentary
on it as opposed to just let's just pluck it out
and put it here yeah it's like i do like the the
the way this show i've i've heard some reviews
com kind of liking it to being less of like a
satirical commentary world and more like a mirror
world to ours that just happens to have soups
and so yeah this i feel like they do a good job
generally of writing a fine line of going that's
the language that i hear for these conversations
in real life but yeah packaged up in a way where
it doesn't glare out and i feel like yeah while
i appreciate the intention of especially that
scene as that speech goes down as the fight breaks
out it is one of the few times where the yeah it's
like you said the overtness kind of does pierce
through the artifice and then you're like oh i can
kind of feel like bullet points of the sentiment
for this scene rather than it feeling like
i almost feel like that scene could have used just
a little bit more breathing room to get us there
so that you can finesse that stuff because
you're getting the you're showing it you're
getting the point across yeah without needing to
be so on that you don't need to call it antifa
and all these like i would i would have picked up
on like yeah they're commenting on antifa without
it's like they're at the point now where like you
might as well call this trumpism with homelanders
you know yeah but i'm like i already pick up
on it without you having to say it you know
yeah yeah um and especially with homeland or stuff
like a lot of that you know is so trumpian yeah
and he uses a similar language but yeah it's not
like exactly just coming out and saying it's this
and i mean i'll give you i feel like you know
you can get a black lives matter or one of the
actual world catch uh slogans or or repeat phrases
or mantras or motifs in there but when you start
to kind of get a tops game of them going it does
feel like you are aiming for those you know uh
you're aiming to kind of break the wall with
those and sometimes that again subjective taste
and sometimes that will pull me out to the point
where i feel like the the point and impact of what
they're trying to convey actually is not as strong
because i'm being now now i feel like i'm being
told it and i'm like i already get it you know
well yeah we've already heard this language for
the past few years yeah and one thing that's great
about the sensibility of this show is i feel like
while the politics are on display surely and that
must take a certain amount of people off i can't
i can imagine that there's probably a percentage
because of how edgy and harsh the show is and
because it shows multiple perspectives on multiple
aspects of life it's like i could see people
watching it who maybe don't share certain beliefs
that are motivating some of the writing and
that scene was one where i was like i would
imagine a lesser amount of people uh sort of
just being in the rhythm of the show and then not
getting pulled out by that like people who could
benefit from that message and who maybe could you
know uh uh this is coming from people who don't
totally lean towards these political beliefs yeah
it's like us in that scene with with blue falcon
or whatever his name is like you're preaching
to the choir a little bit of course we are on
the side of a train's brother basically like hey
do this the right way for christ's sake um but
yeah it's like i could see somebody who is not on
board with black lives matter watching this and
in certain instances of that kind of commentary
just accepting it as part of the show and not re
not having that knee-jerk reaction that you would
to a more overtly laid out here is a message
you know and i feel like that's a scene that might
miss that opportunity to hook somebody who isn't
on the page with you know this who isn't part of
the choir being preached too yeah you know i think
season two had a great handle on that and uh and
for the most part this one does too oh this season
yeah it's really just you know it's it might sound
like it's nitpicking but i i i don't know to me it
really would be like hey come on you guys uh i've
seen you be insanely good and clever at this for
a long time yeah for like many episodes now like
20 something episodes uh that that that would kind
of pull me out but the context of what they're
doing with slowly watching a train you know kind
of this thing of will he uh be a better person
like he seemed grow his soul because he's he's
constantly been in turmoil and conflict over all
the decisions we've seen him go through even ever
since the first season starting off as a complete
closed-off cold-hearted [__] who killed robin
to now where he's at in his life you know he even
seems in conflict about turning in supersonic and
being kind of ca i mean cowardice about the
whole situation um even this situation with um
yeah with the black community um uh i forget
what hometown their hometown oh god it's uh
it's on the tip of my tongue too he said it um
but yeah whatever that that community is yeah and
um you know what and it becomes personal for him
too and his brothers and now uh in the hospital
and paralyzed is now in a similar situation but
he has no superpowers that atran's been in before
where he can't where he's injured and can't
really move he's a little immobile uh i like
i like the context of that a lot of watching as
a guy who starts off as i'm just doing this to
to play kate and to rebrand myself and my image
to oh there's more personal things that are making
him actually care more in a in a in a more
real way he's realizing that the system of
corporate uh uh of of like corporate virtue
signaling doesn't actually help or get things
done and you can't come from that place as he has
been and expect to enact real meaningful change
on people's lives yeah yeah i appreciate
the context and then frenchie and kimiko
oh like kimiko being excited about being human
you know they set her up with being someone who
because she's always been kind of like a
good secret weapon for the boys you know
uh is this but they've really established and
they've really dumped into a more that she hates
the fact that she is this thing and you know this
this joy at being human and i mean it's kind of
like kind of liking it to like when professor
x and days of future past starts like loses
his ab his abilities he can walk yeah and she's
like slowly getting her voice back and then they
the expressionate way of showing her emotions
to the the music her bonding with frenchie and
all this i feel i really am concerned that
like it's at the point where i'm like oh man
they could kill a frenchie i'm still just having
that tragic ending yeah i'm constantly worried for
frenchie and kimiko's safety and well-being and
i i think they're drawing that story up really
nicely because i feel like there's stakes for
both of them obviously it's like it's great for
kimiko to finally be human but also that means
she's way more vulnerable than she was before
and frenchie i mean yeah he's caught i like his
story of being caught between these alphas and
trying to break out of that loop in that cycle and
uh and yeah i i hope to god they don't kill him
i almost feel like that might be the kind of dance
that these characters have to play sort of as a
motif as they go i like frenchie's story a lot in
some ways he's like the jesse pinkman of the group
um he's he's such a such a sweetheart of a
guy like such a sweetheart of a guy who's
just made some terrible decisions along the way
he's gone on some terrible paths and done some
bad things but he's really at his core um
just as just a really sweet human being and
and and then you know watching him be tugged
around here when i'm like goddamn yeah butcher
you [__] caught him in this [__] situation
now and now he's now he's suffering for it um
and i don't know maybe kimiko is going to
sacrifice her this part of her that needs
to be human and or like try to get back her
powers in order to say frenchie in some way
um so now she'll be on the v24 too yeah maybe
something to ignite it uh yeah i'm liking i'm
i still like this one a lot it's not exactly
the most like i was so shocked that chemical
started talking like that was the most exciting
part to me was like what he's talking about yeah
and great music like i've never even seen
the i don't i've never even seen the actress
i'm assuming she can speak and she or is she
actually a hearing impaired i don't know um i've
never seen any interviews with her so i have no
idea if she's hearing compared or actually speaks
um but yeah or yeah i mean or yes i mean she
can't be a mute i don't think for for real i don't
know if that's the correct term i don't know the
terminology i don't want to offend anyone either
way yeah i'm trying but you guys know what i'm
getting in and sorry if i my choice of words there
was not correct um yeah still i've never seen any
neighbors either so i don't know yeah yeah and i
mean that's kind of neat because yeah because then
she could just exist fully in the characters yeah
she's just purely just chemical to me and there's
i mean so much great body language between them to
always like i love even though there is dialogue
in the sign language like i love things like that
where you really get your performers just emoting
physically you know yeah very true in the deep
rising up clearing out the research team what a
[__] she's going to mess everything up when he's
at herogasm and she's on his wife oh oh he is yeah
oh and then she's going to get with homelander
i mean she's controlling everything i love all you
cut to her she's he's just reciting what she wrote
yeah oh so cringey ass [__] um chase crawford
is so good in that role he is like so good at that
role he you gotta give respect because he really
is willing to just come in with with no dignity
he's the least cool guy he really feels
like somebody's kid brother is just trying
bending over backwards to be cool and accepted he
exists to be like a punchline yeah and uh and yet
he brings such humanity to the character i think
chase crawford's work on it is actually pretty
underrated he's he's really great in this yeah
um you got to be game like a really big game he's
playing this game exists to be pathetic yeah and
he just had to find new lows like chase crawford
is like a really dashingly good looking dude
and like a very like physically fit guy yeah
he has the the natural looks of a guy who
could be a superhero um but i love how he
just plays it as such a pathetic human being
yeah he's so good in the role yeah so good yeah
totally uh so yeah i mean overall really somber
[__] uh this is probably like the one with the
least exciting stuff in it and paul reiser
holy [__] paul riser showing up in here
yeah yeah yeah paul ryzer and russia two things
very much tear it over yeah carried over from
stranger things it's pretty nuts to see like the
similarities yeah and r.i.p lori holden goodbye
crimson countess i actually thought she would
last a little longer than these couple appearances
i mean i like paul reiser's performance a
lot it felt like a commentary and like that
not exactly like a harvey weinstein but it's
like a [__] music entertainment producer yeah
big mogul of entertainment yeah yeah he's maybe
retired now but still very much about that life
yeah he's got that layer of slime on him
yeah so so naturally he's uh he's just uh
a few rewrites away from being a guy in like a
a robe with a bunch of curly hair vegan elliott
yeah yeah right you're right
on the brink of being that
um but yeah guys what do you think about
this episode leave your thoughts down below
thank you athletic greetings for sponsoring this
video yeah and last but not least to a patreon
eric if there's anyone at this patreon i want to
see in this world it's you because you know why we
got a herogasm on the horizon and if anybody
deserves a lifetime pass to an event called
herogasm it would be you my friend because think
about the things we've seen already in this show
think about the toys and instruments
that were used nearly an episode ago
i want to see you with that star spangled
strap on my friend i want to see you in some
super chaps you know compound or or v24 and up
you know what super imagine the super powers
eric horstmann would have he could probably
like break things in half just by clenching
his butt cheeks or something like that you
know i think you are the perfect person to
descend not ascend but descend to the depths of
depravity but also do it with the utmost style
and the utmost enthusiasm to the point where
it looks like a good idea that we would want
to try yeah it's not but it would look good on
you and that's why it's your day buddy you're
the man you're the man let's oil ourselves
up and uh lose track of where who begins